on se transporte en 1979 sur l'immense
chantier de la baie james
on parle beaucoup d'autonomie
alimentaire et de production de légumes
locaux ces jours ci et bien vous allez
voir que ces préoccupations ne date pas
d'hier
par tél g4 est à 450 km à l'est de la
baie james et à 950 km au nord de
montréal
au temps des loisirs certains
s'emploient à la culture des légumes
des chercheurs en partenariat avec
l'université du québec à chicoutimi
avait construit sur ce site des petites
serres expérimentales révolutionnaire
pour l'époque ont tenté entre autres de
comprendre comment cultiver des légumes
sous des latitudes aussi nordique pour
conserver la chaleur au maximum des
tunnels recouvrait les cultures à
l'intérieur des serres vous avez des
arceaux sur ces arceaux là vous mettez
vos deux plastique le translucide
l'aluminé pour la protection la nuit et
enfin vous avez de cette serre qui
inclut le tout et qui encore
l'ajustement nous permet d'économiser de
l'énergie car l'espace à l'intérieur les
très exigu est ce un petit tunnel à
l'intérieur est ce que vous devez vous
en servir également à l'année longue ou
si pendant l'été oui disons qu'ici vous
avez environ 13 nuits durant l'été où
vous aurez pas de gel
alors le soir les gens qui pilote ce
projet la vienne
rabat la membrane de plastifier même
pendant le même pendant l'été aux effets
à noter on a des câbles chauffants à
l'intérieur de la terre et ses câbles
chauffants réchauffe le seul la nuit à
votre source de l'énergie donc c'est
l'électricité presspass et à
l'électricité principalement et la
grande caractéristique de cette servent
comme on le mentionnait au tout début
c'est qu'elle ne requiert que 10% de
l'énergie qui serait requise dans une
serre conventionnelle des contrôles
thermostatiques permettait aussi de
gérer la température de façon précise
pour répondre aux besoins des plantes
tout en économisant l'énergie mais le
plus étonnant de cette expérience c'est
le sol dans lequel poussent et légumes
est-ce qu'on utilise et
le meur terrain qui provient du décapage
des ouvrages de lg cat et on aurait pu
utiliser du promix par exemple mais là
on aurait triché concédions feng serre
qui est vraiment celle de tiger on
récupère se marrent terrain on y ajoute
de la chaux et ça semble très prometteur
comme vous pourrez constater d'autres
centrales comme lgi de caniapiscau
posséder aussi leur sert à lg 4 le
projet de serres a duré quelques années
pendant la construction de la centrale
cette expérience a permis de fournir
tomates laitues et autres concombres à
quelques-uns des 4000 travailleurs du
chantier et leurs familles